LAKS LAKSHMANAN:
Welcome to Cloud OnAir,
live webinars from Google Cloud.
We're hosting webinars
every Tuesday.
My name is Laks
Lakshmanan, and I'm
going to be talking about
a development workflow
when you're building end-to-end
machine learning models
with TensorFlow on
Google Cloud Platform.
You can ask questions anytime
and we have Googlers on standby
to answer them.
So this talk that
I'm going to be doing
is basically going to be walking
through a set of code labs.
And the code lab is
here on that link,
and it's essentially about
building an end-to-end machine
learning model.
We'll walk through all of the
steps in order to do that.
But before we do
that, let's talk
a little bit about what
machine learning looks
like on Google Cloud.
So what we are
going to be doing is
that we're going to be using
distributed TensorFlow on Cloud
ML Engine.
And when you look at TensorFlow,
you have varying levels
of abstraction levels, with the
bottom level essentially being
how you run core
TensorFlow in C++.
But more commonly, people do
core TensorFlow in Python,
which essentially calls the
C++ API to get high performance
on a variety of
different devices,
whether they are CPUs
or GPUs, et cetera.
The level at which
we will be working at
will be tf.estimator.
This is a very high level
out-of-the-box API that handles
distribution training for you.
So why do we talk about
distributor TensorFlow?
When we look at a lot of
machine learning frameworks,
they can handle what
I call toy problems.
Toy problems are problems where
the input fits into memory.
Well, you take your data,
your inputs, your training,
your model, and you
have your model, right?
And if all you have are small
data sets, then that's fine,
and that's what I
call a toy problem.
But in order to build
effective machine learning,
you need three things.
And the first and foremost
thing that you need
is large amounts of data.
And if you have big data, if
you have large amounts of data,
then batching and distribution
become extremely important.
You need to take your inputs,
and you can't read all of them
from memory all at once.
You have to break it up
into chunks and read them.
You can't go ahead and train
your model on one CPU or GPU.
You often have to distribute
to multiple compute nodes.
And once you have batching
and you have distribution--
and this is something
that you need when
you have large data sizes--
then TensorFlow starts
to play a huge role.
The other thing
that you need when
you want to build
effective machine learning
is that you need what's
called feature engineering.
This is where you don't
use the raw inputs as is,
but you take your raw inputs and
you do transformations of them.
You may preprocess those inputs.
You may create features.
And we look at
examples of those,
and it's on those features
that you train your model.
And the reason to do this
is that the raw data,
it can be pretty noisy.
And it can be
relatively hard and take
many, many, many epochs and
a much more complex model
for the model to learn
from the raw data, where
if you've done
feature engineering,
it might be easier for
your model to learn.
So the third thing
that you need when
you want to build
effective machine learning
is that you need to
be able to experiment
with a variety of different
model architectures.
And that's another place where
TensorFlow comes in extremely
handy, because it is the most
popular tool for deep learning,
and importantly, it's very
popular, both among researchers
and among developers.
So what that means
is that when you're
developing with TensorFlow,
you get the benefit
of, essentially,
being able to build
models that are leading edge.
And you get to do this often
by basically taking open source
code and applying
it to your data.
So that's essentially
what TensorFlow provides.
But what else does a
machine learning framework
need to provide,
besides the ability
to handle large data, the
ability to feature engineering,
and the ability to experiment
and model architectures?
What else do we need?
Well, one thing is
hyperparameter tuning.
Sure, you can train a
model, but oftentimes,
you don't train a model, you
train a family of models.
And you want to
basically go ahead and do
this experimentation
easily, in an automated way,
and that's where
hyperparameter tuning comes in.
Another thing that
you may want to do
is that once you
have your model,
you have clients who are
accessing this model.
And you need to basically
auto scale the prediction code
so that if you have 100
clients or a million clients,
your prediction API scales.
And so you want your
client code to be
able to access your
model not through Python,
not through TensorFlow, but
with just a REST API call,
so that you basically are
able to access this prediction
model from pretty much
any device, any language
that you want.
But then the question becomes,
if the client is basically
going to be making
REST API calls,
who's going to do all of the
preprocessing and feature
creation?
Because your model, the
model that you've deployed,
expects to see
these new features.
So who's going to do that?
Because what the client wants
to give is the raw data.
And that's where Cloud
ML Engine comes in.
Cloud ML Engine helps you
to basically do auto tuning,
helps you to scale
out your predictions,
and helps you maintain
it in such a way
that you get repeatable
results between training
and between prediction.
So the way we go
through the development
workflow in ML Engine is
that you start with Datalab.
And Datalab is in Jupyter
Notebook that's hosted.
So you basically
start with Datalab,
which is in Jupyter Notebook.
And you do it on
a small data set.
Maybe you have a CSV file.
You're doing your
exploration in pandas.
You may be using Apache
Beam, and then you're
writing a TensorFlow model.
You're improving it.
And then you get a
model that works.
And once you have
a model that works,
you don't know
how well it works.
And the way you basically
figure out how well it works
is that you take it
now and you scale
it out to your entire data set.
And you do that on Google
Cloud, where you're basically
using things like Cloud data
to do your preprocessing.
You're reading your
data off Cloud storage,
and you're running your model on
many machines using ML Engine.
And that helps you, on all of
these things, are serverless.
You don't have to
manage any clusters.
You don't have to manage
any infrastructure.
So that's basically
the end-to-end workflow
that I'm going to
be walking through.
So we're going to start
with how to take your data,
explore it, visualize
it, and then
to create a smaller part of
that data to play around with,
to create your sample
data set, and then
to be able to develop your
first TensorFlow model.
And having gotten
your model, you
want to now try it out
on the entire data set.
So you go back and you create
your training and evaluation
data sets that are large,
that are over the entire data.
And having done that, you
execute the training--
this model that you
have developed--
you execute the
training, you deploy it,
and then you basically
access it from other clients,
for example, from
a web application.
So these are the seven
kind of steps in this.
And this link takes
you to the code lab
and to the GitHub repository.
So here is the code
lab, and here's
a GitHub repository
that contains
all of these notebooks.
Or that's notebook 1.
That's notebook 2, notebook
3, et cetera, all the way.
So we'll basically go ahead
and walk through each of them
one by one.
So the first thing is
to explore the data.
Now, the model that
I'm going to be doing
is going to be a
structured data model.
And you might say,
wait a second.
You're doing structured data.
Isn't that boring?
Well, it's kind of boring, yes.
Images and sequences
get all the press.
But even at Google, where we've
been doing machine learning
for a long time, MLP,
multilayer perceptrons--
which are basically the
kind of model that we use
for structured data--
that is nearly 2/3
of all the models
that we have in production.
LSTMs, which are sequence
models, the kinds of things
that you do for time series and
for text, they're another 30%.
The Hello World, [INAUDIBLE]
of the world, the images,
that's less than 5%
of production models.
So if you're starting
out in machine learning
and you're saying, what
should I concentrate on?
Where do you start is
with structured data,
so that's where
we're going to start.
So our goal in here is
that we want to predict
the weight of a newborn.
So this is the
health care data set.
And the idea is that
if you can predict
the weight of a
newborn, we can identify
babies that might need special
facilities, incubators,
et cetera, and then get babies
the care that they need.
So the idea is that a pregnant
woman walks into a doctor's
office, and based on a
variety of measurements
that the doctor
has, they want to be
able to predict what the
weight of that newborn
is, which is a
pretty good indicator
of the health of the baby.
So how do we do that?
We need a data set, and the
data set that we're going to use
is an open data set collected
by the US government.
It's all the births recorded
in the 50 states in the US.
So this is called a
natality data set.
It's about 137 million rows,
pretty reasonable sized data
set that we can use to
demonstrate the kinds of things
that we want to do.
So this data set includes
things like the birth,
the date of birth, the
location of the birth.
Also, the baby's birth
weight in pounds.
This is going to be our label.
This is the thing that
we're trying to predict.
And things like the mother's
age at the time of birth,
the gestation weeks, how
long was the pregnancy?
Was it a preemie pregnancy?
Was it full term, et cetera.
So those are the kinds
of features that we have
that we can use as predictors to
predict the weight of the baby.
So first thing, to explore
and visualize the data set.
So if you go to the
code lab link there,
so number one is to
explore the data.
So we basically are
going to go ahead and go
into the Cloud Shell icon.
So I already have that
running here, so there it is.
Here's my Cloud Shell.
OK.
And in here, I can
go into Cloud Shell.
I can then basically run the
first command, G-Cloud Compute
Zones list, which is here.
So go down there.
G-Cloud Compute Zones list.
This tells me all the compute
zones that are available,
and you want to go ahead
and pick a zone that's
close by to where you live
to reduce your latency
and to basically
have your compute
in that particular region.
The next step is to basically go
ahead and create a Datalab VM.
Just to save time,
I've already done this,
so I'll skip that step.
And the third thing is to go
into the BigQuery console.
So we can go to the
BigQuery console
by going into here,
into the GCP console.
Going down, let's go
into the BigQuery.
There is BigQuery.
And once we are in
BigQuery, we want
to go ahead and compose a query.
And the query that we
want to compose is this.
And we want to do
this in standard SQL.
So I'll just go ahead
and do standard SQL.
Another way to do this is
to go into Show Options
and turn off the
Legacy SQL query.
So let's go ahead and
do the standard SQL.
That is the query
that I want to run.
The query is that I'm going
into this data set called
Public Samples Natality.
And I'm basically
picking up all the births
that are between 2000 and 2005.
Let me go ahead
and run the query.
And I'm basically going ahead
and finding the plurality.
The plurality is
whether a single child
was born, whether it's
twins, whether it's
triplets, whether it's
quadruplets, or quintuplets.
Or we see, for example, that
single kids are obviously
the highest.
There were about half a
million, 500,000 or so, twins,
and about 28,000
triplets, et cetera.
So that's the data set.
And remember, this is
a huge data, right?
137 million rows.
We were able to process
it in about four seconds.
So that's a power BigQuery here.
And we didn't create a cluster.
We didn't set up
any infrastructure.
I just went into
BigQuery and I said,
this is the class
[? tray ?] I want.
This is the query
that I want to run.
And at that point,
thousands of nodes,
essentially, processed
my query for me.
And that's why I was able to get
back the results on this pretty
large data set.
I'm only picking two columns,
or actually three columns,
which is why only three
gigs of data got processed.
So a big query is a
column or database.
It only processes the columns
that your query actually
references.
And we're able to basically go
ahead and get our results back.
So let's go ahead into
the next step in here.
So this is cool.
I get my table.
The table isn't
very interesting.
What we want are graphs.
We're data scientists.
We want graphs.
So let's go into Cloud DataLab.
This is cloud DataLab.
And in cloud Datalab, let's go
ahead and start a new notebook.
And in that notebook
that I have started,
let me go ahead and
take, essentially,
a very similar query.
So here's my notebook.
I will go ahead and
set up my query.
And I'm basically importing
the BigQuery package.
And I'm basically getting DF,
which is a pandas data frame.
And I'm going ahead
and doing df.head,
which shows me the first few
elements of that data frame,
just to make sure that we have
something reasonable to plot.
So this is, essentially,
doing the same thing
that we did on the
BigQuery console,
but I'm now doing it from
Python from my Datalab notebook.
The next cell, we
want to do this.
Let's do this.
So we see that we
basically got a few
of the rows, the
weight in pounds,
whether the baby
was male or not,
the mother's age, et cetera.
But the next thing
that I want to do
is to basically go ahead
and get the distinct values
of a particular column.
Is the baby male or
is the baby female?
And go ahead and do a bar plot.
So let's go ahead and do this.
So this is where Python starts
to come in really useful.
So we can basically do
all of our normal plotting
that we do in Python.
And we see, for
example, that there
are a few more male
babies than there are
female babies that are born.
Actually, this is
the average wait.
So this is,
essentially, male babies
are slightly heavier
than female babies.
And we can also do the same
thing for gestation weeks.
So I'll go ahead and do
this for gestation weeks.
And notice that each of
these things that I'm doing,
I'm doing them
pretty interactively.
But each of this
piece of lines of code
are actually processing
hundreds of millions of lines,
of four rows of data.
So now, we're basically seeing
that there are-- let me just
make this slightly bigger.
So with 17, week
of pregnancy 18,
week of pregnancy,
et cetera, you
see that the weight of
the babies tends to go up.
And then basically, once the
babies get almost full term,
it kind of evens out.
So that's the first step.
We've explored the data.
We've kind of seen how
the average weight,
which is the kind of thing
that we want to predict,
how it varies with one
predictor-- in this case,
the gender of the baby--
and another predictor, which
is the gestation weeks.
How long has the
pregnancy lasted?
So let's move back to this.
So that was the first step,
to explore and visualize
the data set.
We did that with
Datalab using BigQuery.
And having done
this, we basically
got graphs like this
that said that, sure,
the gender of the baby matters.
Sure, the plurality.
I did not show you this, but
you could also do other columns
in the data set.
So in this case, was it a single
child or twins, et cetera?
Twins tend to be a lower
weight than single children,
for example.
So you can basically
go ahead and do this
and find which features matter.
So having done that, we have
now identified our predictors,
and we are off to basically
do the next step, which
is to basically now use--
to go ahead and create our data
set based on those predictors
that we have chosen.
So to build a machine
learning model,
the first step is to
create the data set.
That is, to go ahead and pull
out the important predictors.
We've now explored
the data, we're
ready to go ahead and
create the data set.
And to create a data set,
we need to also think about
one more thing.
The thing that we need to
think about is causality.
Will we actually know
the sex of the baby
and the plurality of the baby
so that we can predict it,
predict the weight of a baby?
Well, we will if an
ultrasound is carried out.
We won't if there
was no ultrasound.
So what we need to do is
we need to figure out a way
to work with this partial data.
Sometimes we know the data.
Sometimes we know the
prediction, the predictor,
and sometimes we don't.
So let's look at how to
basically create the sample
data set in BigQuery.
So here, we'll move on to step
number 2, to create a data set.
And there, I will basically
go ahead, in DataLab,
I will clone the notebook.
So let's go down here,
and in here, let's just
clone the notebook.
And this will essentially go
to GitHub, pull in the code.
And at this point,
I can go into here
and I see my training data
analyst, and in there.
So this prevents it from
having to copy and paste code
every time.
I can go into the directory
that's pointed out.
So this is the same GitHub
repo that I showed you earlier.
So deep dive, and this
is the structured data.
And in there, we are now on
to the second of the labs.
And in this lab, once
a notebook comes up,
you notice that there are three
lines here about the bucket
and the project.
Those are in Qwiklabs.
So we'll go into Qwiklabs
and get the project ID,
and basically
throw that in here.
So that's my project ID.
And the region is fine.
And I need to go ahead
and have a bucket.
So let's just make sure
that the bucket exists.
So we can go down to the GCP
console, go into Storage.
And once we're in
Storage, we see that, yes,
there is a bucket,
and the bucket
is actually the same name as a
project, conveniently enough.
So we can basically
go down here,
and it's essentially that.
And we'll basically
use that bucket.
And we can run that.
We can run the next cell.
And having done that--
now, we don't need to create it.
The bucket's already there.
And now we can
sample the data set.
So I'm just going ahead and
running them one by one.
You can click Run here.
What I'm doing is I'm
pressing Shift Enter,
but then now I'm grouping
by the hash [? month ?]
and getting my training data.
And once I have
my training data,
I'll stop running through
it, because it's essentially
the results are here.
We can basically look at
what the data set looks like.
We can look at the weight in
pounds, which on average is
7.2 pounds, But the standard
deviation is about 1.3 pounds.
The minimum baby
was half a pound
and the maximum baby
was almost 14 pounds.
The mother's age,
again, you have it.
But notice something
interesting.
The weight in pounds
and the mother's age,
there are different numbers.
Why would that be?
Well, because sometimes
you have missing data,
and pandas doesn't count nulls.
And so we have some babies
in our data set for whom
the weight wasn't recorded.
We have some pregnancies, a lot
of pregnancies, it looks like,
for which the gestation
weeks aren't known.
So we need to deal
with that as well.
So what we're doing is that,
in our preprocessing in pandas,
we make sure that the weight
in pounds is greater than 0,
that the mother's age
is greater than 0,
that the gestation
weeks is greater than 0,
and the plurality
is greater than 0.
So we are just
filtering the data
to make sure that we are only
dealing with valid data sets.
And then, remember
what we talked about,
that sometimes you know it
and sometimes you don't.
So here's how we're
dealing with it.
We're basically taking the
numbers 1, 2, 3, 4, and 5,
and replacing them with single,
twins, triplets, et cetera.
And we are basically
going to simulate
the lack of an ultrasound.
So for every row in our input
data, we create one more row.
And the second row is going
to be a copy of the first row,
except the plurality is only
going to be single or multiple,
the idea being that we don't
know if it's twins or triplets,
but we do know if it's
one kid or two kids.
And the gender of the baby
is going to be unknown.
So now, the gender of the baby
can be three possible values,
male, female, or unknown.
And the plurality can be single,
twins, triplets, quadruplets,
quintuplets, but
also multiple plus.
So that's the basic thing
that appear in our data.
And we create that
pandas data frame
and we basically go ahead
and write it all out.
So at this point, if you
go ahead and look at--
here, we haven't run this yet.
So I can go ahead and
run all the cells.
And at this point, all of
the cells will get run.
At the very end, I will
basically have my CSV files
that I can now use for the next
step, which is to basically
train my TensorFlow model.
So let's move back here.
And I'm going to
basically move fast
because I think you get the idea
of how you walk through this.
So one of the things that
I kind of glossed over
as I went through was that
the way I split my data
was that I didn't use rand.
Instead, what I did
was that I used a hash.
And the reason to use a hash
rather than a rand is that
in this data set-- and this is
going to be common with a lot
of different data sets--
is that the rows
are not actually
independent of each other.
If you have triplets,
you have three babies.
So you have three
rows in your data,
and those three rows
are for the same month.
So it's the same number
of gestation weeks,
the same mother's age,
the same everything.
So they are not really
independent rows.
And you don't want to
actually put those rows,
like one of those
rows in training
and another of the
rows in evaluation.
So what we do is that we
make a hash of the row
and we divide based on the hash.
So we've now created
our sample data set.
The next step is
to build the model.
To build the model,
the thing to realize
is that there are two types
of features in our data.
We have dense features and
we have sparse features.
Dense features are
features like the price,
which is a continuous number.
And sparse feature is
a categorical feature,
like an employee ID, or
the gender of the baby.
Is it male, is it
female, or is it unknown?
That's a categorical variable.
So you have dense variables
and you have sparse variables.
And deep neural
networks are really
good for dense,
highly correlated data
because of the way they work
with adding and subtracting
data between layers.
But on the other
hand, sparse networks
are really well-suited
to linear models.
So if you have sparse features,
you want to use linear models.
If you have dense
features, you want
to use deep neural networks.
But in this case, we have both.
So what do we do?
We use what's called a
wide and deep model, where
we take all of our
sparse features
and we put them into the
wide part of the network,
and we take all of
our dense features
and we put them in the
deep part of the network.
And the way you do
this in TensorFlow
is to use what is called a DNN
Linear Combined Classifier.
So we basically are
going to do this
and we're going to take some
of our features and say,
these are our linear future
and these are our DNN features.
So let's go ahead and
take a quick look.
And in this case,
what I'll do is
I'll just step through
the code on GitHub itself.
But you can basically do this.
You can run the code and
you can train the model.
So here, as before, you change
your bucket, your project.
And having done that,
here's a TensorFlow code.
We import TensorFlow.
We say my data set contains
the CSV columns, the weight
in pounds, is the baby male,
the mother's age, the plurality,
and the gestation weeks.
And what you want to predict
is the weight in pounds.
And having done that,
to read the data set,
I'm going to basically go
ahead and glob all file names.
Globbing is basically putting in
a wild star, like an asterisk.
So basically go
ahead and reading
all the files that have
a particular prefix.
Because in reality, it will
not be reading one file,
it will be reading a
set of sharded files.
So I'll be able
to say train star.
So having done that, I say
this is a text data set.
Read it line by line
and decode the CSV.
How do I decode the CSV?
I take the CSV, and
these are my columns.
So basically, those
are my defaults.
That's my columns.
So for each of them,
take out the label,
because that's not a feature.
So you have your features,
which are one set of columns.
And you have the
label column, which
is this one column,
the original data set.
So having done that, then go
ahead and shuffle the data.
Shuffling is a good thing to
do in distributed training
so that each worker gets a
different copy of the data,
in essence, or is processing
a different slice of the data
at the same time.
And you basically go ahead and
repeat the data as many times
as you need, and that's
how you read the data.
And now, we basically
say, given our data,
how do we form our wide
columns or our deep columns?
Well, we basically
say that the is
male is a categorical column.
Mother's age is
a numeric column.
Plurality is a
categorical column,
and this is the vocabulary.
And the gestation weeks
is a numeric column.
So you basically specify
what type of column it is,
and that's our input data.
And what I'm now
doing is that I'm
going to take my common
columns, my numeric columns,
and do what is
called bucketizing.
I'm going to discretize them,
to basically put them into bins.
And in this case,
I'm just putting them
into bins of 15 to
45 in steps of one.
And then I'm going
to do the same thing
for the gestation weeks.
And now, my wide columns are
the is male and the plurality--
those are both sparse--
but also the discretized
numeric columns.
And having done that-- now this
is kind of where TensorFlow
comes in really
handy, is that it
can do all these very
sophisticated things.
So sure, I've discretized
it, but now I'm
going to basically go ahead
and do my feature crossing.
And I'm going to feature cross
these extremely sparse data
to basically create,
in effect, something
like 20,000 new columns
of feature crossing.
I can afford to do this because
my data set is very large.
So having done that, I then
do dimensional reduction
to a set of three.
Now, the question is, do
you need to do all this?
If I didn't do any
of these things,
if I just took my raw data and
I did it, I would lose about 30%
in [? RMSE. ?] So I get
about 30% improvement
by doing some of these
sophisticated feature
crosses, et cetera.
And then I basically
create my deep column
so I have my wide and deep.
And then I can
train and evaluate.
By creating a DNN
Linear Regressor
with the wide columns,
with the deep columns,
and then saying what it is
I need to do for training.
I'm going to retrain that CSV.
What do I need to do
for my evaluation?
Evaluate on eval.csv.
So that's pretty much it.
And I do one thing else.
Now, this is something that
a lot of people don't do,
but a very good thing
to do, something
that you want to get
into the habit of doing,
because it's going to be useful
for every step after this,
is that I also export the model.
The reason to export a model
is to basically take my model
that I've trained and
put it into a form
where it can be quickly wrapped
up and used for production.
So I basically export my model.
And when you're
exporting a model,
you need to think
about-- remember
I talked about the REST
API by which you access it?
So here's the things
that someone is going
to give us in that REST API.
They're going to give us the is
male, mother's age, plurality,
and gestation weeks.
What does this look like?
It basically looks
something like this.
Somebody would be able
to go into and create
an application that
looks like this, where
that's the mother's age, this is
the number of gestation weeks.
And I expect that it is twins.
Both of them are male.
And go ahead and predict.
So that's the idea that we
want to do when we're basically
creating a TensorFlow model.
So having done
that, the next step
is to preprocess the
data with Dataflow.
So we've created a
TensorFlow model.
It's being developed.
The next step is to
operationalize the model,
is to take that model
and operationalize it.
Now, this model we
created is ready to go,
except we don't have
the full data yet.
Now, the way we created
the small data set before
was to use pandas.
pandas is fine
for experimenting,
but if you want to
operationalize you workflow,
you want to make it repeatable.
You want to have it deal
with streaming data.
You want to do your
preprocessing not in pandas,
but in something
that's very scalable,
something like Apache Beam.
So that is going
to be our next lab.
So the idea is to basically
write this Apache Beam pipeline
and lob it off to
Cloud Dataflow,
to the servers that
will run this for us.
It will auto scale all
of these predictions,
and it'll basically give us
a number of things that are
[? run. ?] So we are now
here onto the next notebook,
which is on preprocessing.
And I'll skip to the key
part of this notebook.
And the key part
of this notebook
is that we are
reading from BigQuery.
We are reading the
data from BigQuery,
and we are doing the same
things that we did in pandas,
except that we are now
doing it in Apache Beam
so that it can also
work on streaming data.
So imagine that you have
data about births coming in
from all the clinics
in the country,
as they are streaming into
[INAUDIBLE] you can read them.
You can do this preprocessing,
and then you can stream them
out of your database.
So we are basically creating
a no ultrasound and a
with ultrasound.
And if it's no ultrasound,
the gender is unknown.
And then we are
basically going ahead,
and if the plurality is
greater than 1, it is multiple.
And also, when I go
ahead and do the query,
I do the filtering,
is a weight in pounds
greater than 0, et cetera.
So we basically go
ahead and do this.
And we lob it off.
Now, once you run
this notebook, it
will lob off the
code into Dataflow.
A few minutes later,
you will basically
have your large data set
that's been created on,
in this case, five nodes.
In this case,
actually, 15 nodes.
The current [? CPU ?] is 15.
So it just basically
goes ahead and does it
on however many
workers you specify.
And having done that, the next
step is to train on ML Engine.
Again, next notebook.
And the key point here,
in terms of training,
is very, very, very
straightforward.
You have your code.
You basically tell ML
Engine, here's my code.
It exists in this
Python package.
Please train it for me.
That's pretty much it.
You run a single command.
It basically lobs it off
and it creates the machines.
If it's on a GPU, it
basically attaches GPUs
to those machines.
It does the training,
and the trained model
shows up on Cloud Storage.
And once a trained model
is on Cloud Storage,
even while it's
training, you can
do your monitoring, et cetera.
Then you deploy it.
Deploying, again, last notebook.
To deploy it, it's, again, just
a single command line call.
Again, once you write
a TensorFlow model,
everything after that is
essentially just single command
line calls.
You basically say,
G-Cloud ML Engine, please
create a version of this
model from this TensorFlow.
And then once that's
deployed, any time it
receives a JSON of this
form, it basically goes ahead
and sends back a
prediction, which
is why something
like this just works.
So we can say the
mother's age is 30.
There's 6.2 pounds.
If it's a single child,
what is the prediction that
7.9 pounds, et cetera.
Boom, boom, boom.
You're basically
getting predictions back
because you've
essentially deployed it.
Then that's pretty much
the end-to-end process
of going ahead and
building a model.
So bottom line,
explore your data.
Create your sample data set.
Create a TensorFlow model.
And then operationalize it using
Dataflow and using ML Engine.
And I'll skip this part.
That's just building
a web application.
And with that, just stay
tuned for a live Q&A,
and we'll be back in
less than a minute.
OK, let's go to questions.
All right.
OK, so questions here.
First question, is
there a way to do this
without using Datalab?
Can I use my own Jupyter build?
Absolutely.
So Datalab is actually
an open source thing.
So let's go ahead and
do GitHub and search
for pydatalab, which is
the project that's in.
And pydatalab is a package.
So you can basically
go ahead and do
a pip install of
pydatalab within Jupyter,
and then you will have
all of these capabilities
that I talked about, all of
the connections to BigQuery,
and ML Engine, et cetera.
So that's all you really need.
So go into the Google
Datalab project.
Datalab is the full
notebook itself,
but pydatalab is the library
that this thing uses,
and this is the
pip-installable package.
So you can go ahead and
install it from within Jupyter.
So if you're using
your own Jupyter
build, no problem at all.
You can still do all this.
Next question.
Why did you use Cloud Dataflow
to do the preprocessing?
What are my other options?
In particular, can I use
something like Spark?
Absolutely.
The reason I use Cloud
Dataflow is because I always
think about streaming,
and streaming to me
is the limit of where
things are going to go.
Anything that you're doing
in batch today-- people
want to do things faster and
faster, and the limit of that
is that you want to do
it as the data comes in.
And the nice thing about
doing it in Dataflow
is that it's the same code
that works on both batch data,
historical data, and
newly arriving data,
or streaming data.
But you can do this in Spark.
The only problem
is that you will
have to write it twice, once for
batch, once in Spark streaming.
Third question.
How much does all this
cost to do on Google Cloud?
Not very much, actually.
The Dataflow job to go ahead
and [AUDIO OUT] data set
was about maybe $2 or $3.
The ML Engine, to go ahead
and do the entire training,
cost me maybe about $8 or $9.
I think you could do
this entire workflow
end-to-end in under $20.
And of course, we have
a free trial offer.
So go to Google Cloud Platform,
sign up for the free trial.
You get $300.
So perfectly possible
for you to go ahead
and do all of these code
labs without spending any.